hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on moof university comm
thank you and enjoy in the last video we
saw that we've made IEP and dmap P and
we're going to have these guys as our
isoprene units that we're going to link
together to eventually make squalene
before I actually get into the reactions
though I would do want to mention that
whenever we're talking about one of
these molecules we're going to have a
head end and a tail end so we'll call
the head end the end that has the B
pyrophosphate portion so this here would
be the head end and this would be the
tail end of DM ATP and then IPP this
would be the tail end and this would be
the head end okay that's going to be the
same for any molecules that we'll see
here okay so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to link DMA P P and
IPP and what's going to happen is carbon
number five of DMA P P is going to link
to carbon number one of the IPP and
we're going to lose this pyrophosphate
group here okay so we're going to lose
that blue one there as a pyrophosphate
and this is going to be catalyzed by
parental transferase proneural of course
referring to the isoprene units that
we're talking about so now we have this
molecule here which is geraniol
pyrophosphate which is ten carbons long
each of these five carbon units was
linked to make this so this condensation
reaction here we connected the head unit
to the tail unit so this is a head to
tail condensation okay this next one
we're gonna take geraniol phosphate or
pyrophosphate scuse me and we're going
to link it to the next not an IPP okay
and we're going to get far Nestle pyro
phosphate which is gonna be fifteen
carbons long and we're going to have
this end being the head end and this one
being the tail end here this is the tail
end of IPP and the head end where the
phosphates are and we're going to link
carbon five this red portion to carbon
one of the IPP here of the brown IPP
so that bond is made there so again
we're linking the head to the tail so
this is a head to tail condensation as
well also catalyzed by renal transferase
then we have farnesyl pyrophosphate so
the 15 carbon molecule and what we're
going to do now is we're going to take
that and we're going to use that and
another refinery so pyrophosphate to
make squalene okay and we're going to
link those but before I actually get
into that I want to ask where did this
other 40 so pyrophosphate come from well
it came from these same exact steps
we're just going to do all those things
again so if I if I erase here too to
reveal what's going on over here I
basically have the same exact reaction
shown here that give this other fpp and
I've drawn this other FTP to sort of
mirror the other one here right if we
put a mirror in between them just like
right here right there just mirror
images of each other all right
reflections and whatnot so we're going
to take these two 15 carbon units and
link them together to make squalene down
here and so we're basically going to
link this carbon this fifth carbon here
to this fifth carbon here of these two
brown portions we're going to lose both
of these pyrophosphate groups
we're going to lose both of those and
we're going to link those two carbons
there to give us scalene so in this case
we've got the head o end here in the
tail end here the head end here and
detail end here so here we have a head
to head condensation head to head
condensation and this is going to give
us
squalene okay and this requires nad pH
reductive biosynthesis
makes sense for building cholesterol
long-term here so it makes sense to have
a reductive reducing power in the form
of NADPH and this is catalyzed by
squalene synthase and now we have
scaling this 30 carbon molecule that is
the precursor to cholesterol all we need
to have now is stage 4 which is the
civilization so I hope this video was
helpful see you in the next one thanks
for watching and be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and share the video with
anyone new thing might find it helpful
thanks happy studying